ولدي خمسة ملايين متابع على
إنستغرام لدي مليون متابع على فيسبوك.
ما أفعله أعطي صوتًا لهؤلاء الأشخاص ،
أريد أن أظهر حقًا أنني أعطي
صوتًا لهؤلاء الأمهات ، يبدو أنني صحفي إيراني
ناشط في مجال حقوق الإنسان
ومثير للمشاكل من أجل  لقد
أدركت أنه كان عليّ أن أحارب من أجل
الديمقراطية
عندما كنت فتاة قروية
وجدت أنني لن
أكون حتى إذا مارست حقوقي الأساسية
فقط فقط استمع إليّ كامرأة
عندما تستيقظ في الولايات المتحدة.
عندما تريد الذهاب إلى عملك إلى
مدرستك إلى الجامعة ، فماذا
تختار ما تريد أن ترتديه؟
ارتديها لتجنب التعرض للعض من قبل
شرطة الأخلاق ،
تبدأ معركتك منذ سن مبكرة عندما
كنت في السابعة من عمري فقط ،
كما تعلم ، كان علي تغطية نفسي للذهاب إلى
المدرسة ، ولم يكن لدي أدنى فكرة عن
التمييز على أساس المساواة أو أنك لا تعرف أن النسوية
لا شيء مرقتي  كان إيه قادرًا على ركوب
دراجة كان أخي قادرًا على لعب
كرة القدم للذهاب إلى الملعب للرقص
والغناء لإظهار شعره ليفعل ما
يريد ، لذلك اعتقدت أن هذا ليس عدلاً ،
فأنا أريد أن أحصل على نفس الحرية التي
طردت من بلدي  قرية ثم
طُردت من مدرستي الثانوية في
بلدتي ثم طُردت من
البرلمان الإيراني لمجرد طرح
العديد من الأسئلة
في نهاية عام 2009 ، طُردت من
وطني الحبيب إيران
جميعًا
لأنني انتقدت الحكومة للتو
هي جريمتي مؤامرة وقحة لاختطاف
صحفية أمريكية من مدينة نيويورك
ونقلها إلى النيابة العامة الإيرانية اتهمت
أربعة مواطنين إيرانيين في هذا المخطط
المزعوم بدعم من الحكومة الإيرانية
بالطبع
أم
التعامل مع
النظام الإيراني أمر مخيف
ولكن لا بد لي من ذلك  أقول لك شيئًا
لسنوات وسنوات ، كنا نحن النساء
الخائفات من نظامهن الآن
هم خائفون منا